[Musik]
ich begrüße sie zu einer neuen ausgabe
unserer reihe unter den linden spezial
anlässlich der bundestagswahlen
interviewen wir spitzenpolitiker und
spitzenpolitikerinnen der im bundestag
vertretenen parteien und mit ihnen über
ihre programme und ziele zu sprechen es
geht um zukunftsweichen die in unserem
land gestellt werden müssen klima
digitalisierung und die zukunft der
sozialversicherungen werfen drängende
fragen auf die eine antwort bedürfen
nach der linken der fdp der csu und spd
folgt heute nun die afg und ich begrüße
bei uns timo copala den
spitzenkandidaten in der afc in diesem
bundestagswahlkampf
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
im bundestag sind sie auch noch und sie
sind auch bundessprecher soll doch alles
erwähnt seien herzlich willkommen bei
uns danke der controller in dieser
heißen phase des wahlkampfs guckt man
eigentlich mehr drauf welche drei
parteien letztendlich dann tatsächlich
die regierung bilden könnten sie spielen
weniger auf sieg als er auf platz mit
ihnen will auch keiner so richtig eine
koalition bilden die letzte wahl hat sie
2017 zur stärksten oppositionspartei
gemacht was ist diesmal ihr ziel ja wir
wollen sicherlich mit dem ähnlichen
ergebnis wieder im bundestag einziehen
vielleicht sogar mit einer steigerung
dass das ziel und die demografen geben
uns ja aktuell auch ein bisschen recht
sind am anziehen also nehmen wir wahr
dass die bürger doch unsere themen
aufgreifen dass wir die alternative zu
den anderen parteien darstellen das ist
unser ziel und das wollen wir natürlich
auch weiter vertreten auch als stärkste
oppositionskraft vielleicht aber auf
alle fälle als wahrnehmbare einzige
opposition im deutschen bundestag die
anderen parteien müssen sich heute
irgendwie in irgendeiner form schon
koalitionsfragen stellen also gibt es
viele möglichkeiten fast jede partei
kommt darin auch vor sie nicht in den
letzten vier jahren im bundestag hat
sich jetzt das auch nicht irgendwie so
verändert dass parteien auf sie
zugekommen sind und stärker an sie heran
gerückt sind die haltung der anderen
parteien die hat sich ihnen gegenüber
eher verfestigt als dass sich da
ressentiments aufgelöst hätten sie
bleiben sozusagen ich sag mal so ein
stück weit unvermittelbar woran liegt
das in ihrer selbst sicht gut wir haben
natürlich auch von unserer programmatik
her auch in unserem wahlprogramm
sicherlich andere ziele wir wollen einen
kompletten politikwechsel in diesem land
und das schmeckt sicherlich den anderen
parteien nicht zu dir sie haben recht im
prinzip können sich alle parteien
miteinander eine kollektion außer mit
der afg vorstellen aber das zeigt ja
eigentlich das ist wie wichtig ist ist
dass wir auch als alternative weiterhin
wahrnehmbar sind und dass wir auch
programmatisch andere themen auch viele
wichtige themen die die bürger
interessieren doch aufgreifen und auch
immer wieder mit dem finger in die wunde
in die wunde greifen und natürlich auch
das thematisieren wollen was sicherlich
einige andere politiker in deutschland
nicht mehr als wahrnehmbar äußern und
das ist ein stück weit politik die wir
vertreten wir sehen dass viele themen in
berlin behandelt werden es habe ich vier
jahre im bundestag erlebt die eigentlich
mit der wirken mit der wirklichkeit der
bürger nichts mehr zu tun hat und das
ist weiterhin so unsere aufgabe und
regierungsbeteiligung ja die wird
wahrscheinlich zuerst in einem
bundesland
vonstatten gehen als im bund in der
bundesrepublik in berlin das heißt sie
fühlen sich auch ganz wohl in dieser
außenseiterrolle und ist das nicht
vielleicht sogar so es ist diese
außenseiterrolle so dass sie
letztendlich auch ihr klientel an sie
binden
ja das ist ja das ziel der politiker ich
vertrete die bürger in meinem wahlkreis
ich vertrete natürlich auch die bürger
die unsere politik gut finden und wie
gesagt wenn wir uns jetzt die aktuellen
umfragen anschauen es gibt ja nur keine
partei die hier mit 40 50 prozent ihrer
wählerschaft hinter sich bringen kann
wir erleben gerade in der jetzigen zeit
doch ein sehr großes schwanken ich nehme
wahr dass es durchaus ein politik ein
wille zum politikwechsel in diesem land
gibt aber der wähler eigentlich nicht so
richtig weiß wie man werden kann und wie
man wählen soll aber wir wie gesagt
haben ein wahlprogramm was auf gesunden
menschenverstand basiert und was ehrlich
ist ohne versprechungen die ablehnung
der anderen parteien ist oftmals ihr
nicht geklärtes verhältnis zum
rechtsextremismus in den eigenen reihen
wir wollen das hier gar nicht vertiefen
und ich gehe da mal mit dem kölner
verwaltungsgericht dass er entschieden
hat dass vor der bundeswahl
bundestagswahl der streit um die
einstufung der afg als
rechtsextremistischer verdachtsfall
nicht entschieden werden soll zum einen
weil sowohl für die afg positive als
auch negative entscheidung könnte
ansonsten die wahlentscheidung der
bürger zugunsten nur zu lasten der 3
beeinflussen so heißt es da genau
gibt es denn aus ihrer bewertung in den
reihen der fdp
ähnliche persönlichkeiten die sie als
rechtsextreme ecke rechtsextrem
bezeichnet worden na ja also wir haben
keine extremisten unserer partei das
weiß ich streikt zurück und ich mir das
natürlich ein vorwand der altparteien um
uns genau in diese ecke zu drängen und
sie zu diskreditieren uns auszugrenzen
und das ist laufen verfahren sie haben
es gerade erwähnt das führen wir
juristisch aus notfalls bis zum
bundesverfassungsgericht und das gilt es
abzuwarten aber wir können die
geschichte unserer bundesrepublik
deutschland schauen so wurde mit neuen
oppositionsparteien eigentlich generell
immer umgegangen sie wurden genauso
stigmatisiert mit anderen dingen auch
stigmatisiert auch vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wie zb die linke aber auch
die grüne wurde ausgegrenzt die ersten
jahre im deutschen bundestag das müssen
wir ein stück weit durchhalten
nichtsdestotrotz werden wir weiter für
den bürger politik machen und wollen
diese angeboten natürlich auch in den
bundestag tragen aber nochmal einen
anlass diese verdachtsfällen es gibt vom
partner wissen sie der verfassungsschutz
ist politisch instrumentalisiert und das
in dem media immer mehr war auch ich
wurde in teilen beobachtet
verfassungswidrig beobachtet das muss
der verfassung zu löschen ein stück weit
hat sich diese behörde verselbstständigt
und das werden wir juristisch klären und
natürlich auch innerparteilich
bevor wir auf die die inhalte gucken
würde ich gerne noch mal grundsätzlich
fragen
würden sie sagen dass diese wahlen vor
einer besonderen herausforderung deshalb
stehen weil wir in der korona pandemie
sind und diese wahlen auch unter dem
eindruck der korona pandemie stattfinden
auch es gibt denke ich mehrere themen
die diese wahl entscheidend wir hatten
sonst bei bundestagswahlen mein eindruck
sommer ein
thema was gegriffen hat und ich nehme
wahr dass es mehrere sind das ist die
innenpolitik die außenpolitik des corona
ist sicherlich auch die migration was
ein thema sein wird was wieder auf der
tagesordnung steht also auch die soziale
frage reichen unsere renten in zukunft
noch nicht sagen aber das ist denke ich
ein thema auch über unser rentensystem
ist wird sich in der nächsten legislatur
entscheiden also die soziale frankreich
mit dem wohnraum noch leisten was wird
man den stromkosten
so vielfältig und ich nehme auch selbst
in meinen veranstaltungen und auch
meinem am wahlkampfstand war dass die
bürger wirklich querbeat alle
unterschiedliche themen haben und das zu
bündeln wird schwierig aber wir müssen
natürlich zu allen wichtigen themen
antworten finden so corona würde ich
gerne noch ein bisschen aus nachfragen
in die korona zahlen steigen zurzeit
wieder sie haben der verlängerung der
epidemischen notlage im bundestag nicht
zustimmt ist für sie corona schon durch
hat es in den schrecken verloren oder
hatte es auch nie an
ja wir haben ja gesehen dass aktuell
auch die auch die die zahlen natürlich
wieder steigen aber alle übrigen alle
oppositionsparteien in der epidemischen
notlage nicht mehr zugestimmt auch
einige der regierungsparteien also der
cdu knapp zehn prozent der abgeordneten
haben sie sich eben ende dagegen
entschieden weil wir gesehen haben
natürlich was der schaden welcher
schaden verursacht wird vereinigen
wirtschaftlichen bereich und da hat ja
nicht corona den schaden verursacht
sondern der lock down und das müssen wir
einfach analysieren deswegen darf es
natürlich keinen doktor gegeben dass die
zahlen wieder steigen hat natürlich auch
saisonale gründe und das nehmen wir
sicherlich ernst
wir gehen jetzt wieder auf den herbst
sowieso infektionszahlen in diesen
bereichen steigen aber noch mal eine im
sommer letzten jahres was er für eine
eine infektion ist keine erkrankung auch
diese unterscheidung muss es geben die
intensivbetten sind nicht steigt stärker
belegt als vor krone aktuell also von
daher muss man hier ein bisschen ein
stück weit zu gelassenheit wieder kommen
und dass das mahnen wir an und vor allem
dürfen wir nicht die grund und
freiheitsrechte weiter einschränken das
kann man nur auf einen begrenzten
zeitraum das wurde gemacht aber damit
muss auch irgendwann muss schluss sein
was wenn sie das sagen wie es
deutschland denn durch diese ersten
teile der pandemie gekommen vor allen
dingen auch im internationalen vergleich
wir haben internationalen vergleich gibt
es gibt es länder die haben keine
maßnahmen ergriffen beziehungsweise
keinen lockt ton vergriffen die stehen
heute genauso da wie deutschland dh
also wenn ich die schuldenlast die
kredite die wir aufgenommen haben kann
ich nicht davon sagen dass wir gut durch
die krise gekommen sind wir haben
mächtige nachtragshaushalt im bundestag
beschlossen 240 milliarden alleine
dieses jahr 80 milliarden sind für
nächstes jahr anvisiert wir müssen den
bürger erzählen und auch erklären wer
das bezahlen soll und dass wir an die
zukünftigen generation sein oder die
jetzige generation das macht mir schon
große sorge wir haben viele
arbeitsplätze durch corona verloren die
wirtschaft leidet immer noch darunter
und das sind natürlich herausforderung
für die nächsten jahre die wir natürlich
klären müssen also gut durchgekommen
sind wir mit sicherheit nicht durch
diese bisherige krise wenn man noch mal
gucken was wir jetzt sozusagen noch
immer mittragen ball corona zb das
tragen von masken da sind sie
grundsätzlich dagegen wir sind
grundsätzlich dagegen zum beispiel das
für das tragen von masken im
außenbereich die absolut auch in der
weise news ist was auch das tragen von
masken von kindern angeht in schulen und
kindergärten kinder sind keine panini
treiber das hat sich immer wieder auch
von vielen kinder ärzten gibt es
mittlerweile bestätigt haben bewiesen
und das lehnen wir ab dass man zum
beispiel masken tragen sollte in den
bereichen zum beispiel von pflege einem
von krankenhäusern dass es durchaus
nachvollziehbar und das würde ich auch
unterstützen würden sie sagen die korona
politik ist ein klassisches dagegen sein
thema
wir müssen mal schauen was die krone
politik bewirkt hat sie hat die spaltung
in unserer gesellschaft befeuert wird
verstärkt wenn man dürfe das thema
impfen dann noch vielleicht eingehen ist
es genau das gleiche hier wird im
prinzip eine eine zwei klassen
gesellschaft für ungeimpfte geimpfte
erzeugt und das nämlich so insgesamt in
unserem land war dass hier wieder die
bevölkerung gespalten wird im bereich
corona vorher was die migrations krise
dann teilweise ost gegen west frauen
gegen männer jung gegen alt also in
allen bereichen unseres lebens wird die
bevölkerung gespalten und das muss
aufhören das hat natürlich aktuell die
bundesregierung zu verantworten denn nur
die regierenden verantworten das
aktuelle tun wie bewerten sie in dem
zusammenhang denn die kerze in
querdenker szene die querdenker szene
hat oder ich sag mal diejenigen die auf
die straße gehen ihren unmut freien lauf
lassen das ist eine berechtigung die sie
haben jeder hat das grundrecht zu
demonstrieren am letzten wochenende
waren in berlin auch wieder knapp
hunderttausend menschen auf der straße
also die bürger haben ja ein grund warum
sie auf die straße gehen also muss man
diesen auch zu hören jede demonstration
hat das recht will solange sie friedlich
ist auf der straße ihren unmut zu zeigen
und ich finde wir als politiker sind
angehalten und die sorgen und nöte
dieser menschen auch anzuhören
lauert da so eine art
gesellschaftspolitisches
spannungspotenzial und sie als afc
hoffende auch von zu profitieren
ich möchte mich davon profitieren ich
möchte die sorgen und nöte der bürger
war niemand aufnehmen und diese
natürlich auch im parlament zur sprache
bringen also deswegen sagte ich ja wir
reden in berlin teilweise im parlament
über dinge die nichts mit der
wirklichkeit zu tun haben und die
menschen merken immer mehr auch die
gegen die auf die straße gehen deswegen
gehen sie auf die straße man geht ja
nicht auf die straße weil man spazieren
gehen möchte sondern weil man unmut hat
weil man sich mit der lage nicht and i
ffi zieren kann weil man sorgen und nöte
hat und wir sollten die ernst nehmen
wenn aber menschen merken dass sie
eigentlich selbst mit einer
demonstration nichts bewirken weil die
politik sich dafür nicht interessiert
oder weil man sie ausgegrenzt weil man
sie als rechtsextreme bezeichnet als
faschisten oder als revidierten damit
spaltet man die gesellschaft und damit
nimmt man die probleme nicht wahr und
das ist eigentlich der grund nahrung
sogar für extremismus weil dann menschen
sich natürlich überlegen ja wenn die
politik sich unsere sorge nicht mehr
annimmt was können wir dann eigentlich
noch tun das sind sollten wir das als
politiker denn auch im sozialen und
friedlichen interesse deutschlands
warnen und ernst nehmen also sind sie
als afd der politische arm der
querdenker wir sind als fdp afd welche
organisation auf die straße gehen die
haben darf die nichts zu tun das ist wie
gesagt noch jeder hat das recht auf die
straße zu gehen ich interessiere mich
aber durchaus für die inhalte und themen
in dieser organisation alle übrigens das
ist genau das gleiche also ein freudiges
verfügt jetzt auf die straße geht auch
daher ich mir an was die jungen leute
für versorgen haben und das mache ich
genauso als fdp-politiker als wenn auch
querdenker oder die p g auf die straße
geht natürlich das ist doch mal mein
auftrag auch als politiker
sie haben eben schon gesagt der
wahlkampf läuft ein bisschen anders als
es als das normalerweise eigentlich
vielleicht so der fall ist wir haben
über corona schon und wenig gesprochen
dann kam die flut dann kam afghanistan
verstellen solche ereignisse und
naturkatastrophen letztendlich den den
blick für die zukunftsthemen die ja
eigentlich mal im wahlkampf besprechen
und gespalten werden müssten
ja die zukunftsthemen ich habe ja einige
schöne angesprochen auch die sozialen
themen sind natürlich wichtig und die
werden wir uns die nächsten vier jahre
intensiv wenn man diese themen im
bundestag behandeln müssen ich finde wir
haben viele themen gerade und der
regierung merkel die letzten jahre
liegen lassen es gab keine steuerreform
zum beispiel ein wichtiges thema was mit
den energiepreisen angeht
energieversorgung grundsicherung das
sind dinge die wurden liegen gelassen
wir haben die letzten vier jahre so
lange wir im parlament sind von der
regierung keine reformbereitschaft
keinen einzigen thema gesehen und das
kritisieren wir und dafür bot die cdu
und die spd hoffe ich auch
dementsprechend abgestraft wir sehen uns
ja
emotionalisieren diese themen wie corona
afghanistan flut und so was die
wahlkämpfe auch wie empfinden sie das
während sie wahlkampf machen wir
emotionalisieren irgendwann muss ja
fragen wo kommen den emotionen her wenn
die regierung mit den kollegen
lauterbach und sparen panik und angst
verbreiten emotionalisiert das natürlich
ja also wenn wir von der vierten
schlimmsten welle jetzt schon wieder
hören von herrn lauterbach und wir
müssten schon wieder ein lockdown
bringen die menschen sind diese dieser
panik natürlich auch ein stück weit leid
und man hat angst um die zukunft angst
um die zukunft der kinder aber auch um
die finanzen und das ist natürlich ein
stück weit was die regierung hier
wahrscheinlich auch will die bevölkerung
spalten anders kann ich mir das nicht
erklären und damit emotionalisiert man
natürlich und ja das ist sicherlich ein
großes problem was weiter zur spaltung
auch der gesellschaft beiträgt
emotionalisierung ist noch mal das
stichwort in der bundestagswahl 2017
diese der wahlkampf sehr stark geprägt
von der migrationsfrage sie haben jetzt
in verbindung mit dem rückzug aus
afghanistan
diese diese frage wieder in den fokus
gerückt die migrationsfrage
bemühen sie sich jetzt einfach mit
bildern von gestern das auch zu
emotionalisieren und auch angst zu
stellen haben wir nicht die frage zurück
gebracht sondern die bundesregierung mit
dem abzug aus afghanistan und den
einhergehenden folgen und hier sieht man
ja dass wirklich desaströse scheitern
auch der bundesregierung was die
außenpolitik an gerade afghanistan und
für uns ist klar sagte wir wollen 2015
nicht wiederholen wir wollen diese
bilder auch nicht haben wir wollen hier
keine menschen ansturm von migranten die
vor der grenze stehen das muss
verhindert werden und das ist eigentlich
der grund darauf hinweisen und wir
wollen wie gesagt diese zustände nicht
mehr haben wir haben erlebt was 2015 mit
uns bedrückt hat innere konflikte gab
soziale konflikte und das kann
deutschland nicht noch mal verkraften
das ist das der grund warum wir
natürlich auf dieses thema auch eingehen
aber das ist ja noch gar nicht doch wir
sehen uns doch aktuell schon wir sehen
doch aktuell schon die lage in
afghanistan ist auch wie die
bundesregierung im zuge zb der ausreise
von afghanischen flüchtlingen bzw
sogenannte ortskräfte die er gekommen
sind wo sie uns ja auch im bundestag
vollmundig erklärt haben wir fliegen nur
die ortskräfte der
regierungsorganisation aus und es sind
von den 4000 afghanen die gekommen sind
nur 136 ortskräfte dabei gewesen also
hier wird man doch schon wieder belogen
und ihr wahn sich doch schon wieder eine
migration an weil man so natürlich für
diejenigen die ihr nicht herkommen
hätten sollen eine sogwirkung erzeugt
und damit kommt wahrscheinlich auch noch
afghanen über den landweg das heißt die
ortskräfte die jetzt noch da sind sollen
dann auch in afghanistan bleiben wie
gesagt das habe ich ja schon gesagt die
ortskräfte wie zum beispiel der
bundeswehr gl geholfen und die
staatlichen organisationen wie
botschaften in ca da mir gesagt in die
können hier in deutschland asyl
beantragen und können hier auch
herkommen für alles weitere muss für die
flüchtlinge die auf migration muss hilfe
vor ort die prämisse sein also den
ländern den nachbarländern iran auch
dort die unterstützung gehen pakistan
denn eine unterbringung vor ort ist
günstiger und vor allen dingen auch für
die menschen wesentlich verträglicher
als eine migration nach deutschland sie
haben in einem interview mit den
kollegen von der deutschen welle gesagt
ist im falle eines ansturms deutschland
konsequent seine grenzen schützen müsse
und auch bei einem gewaltigen ansturm
müsse man sich verteidigen können
nochmal bemühen sie da nicht alte angst
bilder das ist aber die grundaufgabe
eines jeden staates ist dass man seine
grenzen schützt und das fordern die und
wenn die europäische
momentan aber die müssen wir auch auf
solche fälle vorbereitet sein das ist
doch immer das gleiche problem in
deutschland dass wir uns danach erst
überlegen was könnte man machen ich
finde wir haben auch die hier hat ja
auch die europäische union massiv
versagt wir haben immer einen
europäischen grenzschutz gefordert die
europäische union hat dafür viel geld in
die hand genommen aber wie es ist
existiert immer noch keiner und da sagen
wir natürlich wenn das nicht optional
ist dann brauchen wir natürlich auch
einige deutschen grenzschutz und sie
erinnern sich wir wurden 2017 was
deutschen grenzschutz angeht belächelt
das könne man nicht machen es ginge
nicht bei corona geht es auf einmal dass
man deutsche grenzen doch schützen kann
die eigene bevölkerung reiserückkehrer
kann man kontrollieren über all das geht
auf einmal aber beim grenzschutz was
migration angeht ging es nicht und das
fordern wir wir brauchen keine
massenzuwanderung wir brauchen auch
keine ungezügelte migration wir wollen
national selbst entscheiden wir
herkommen gelaufen und wir nicht sie
haben in dem interview auch gesagt das
wahlkampfprogramm spielt bei den wahlen
eigentlich immer die wenigste rolle oder
die geringste rolle
wir wollen aber in dieser sendung dann
trotzdem mal so ein bisschen auf die
programmatik schauen wir sind ja mit
afghanistan gerade eingestiegen schauen
wir ein bisschen auf die außenpolitik
inwieweit ist das kollektive scheitern
des westens das kann man sicherlich an
der steller so sagen
in afghanistan unsere inwiefern ist das
auch thema im wahlkampf wird das
wahlkampfthema sein
wahlkampf thema die bürger interessiert
das natürlich vor allem was die kosten
angeht was den afghanistan einsatz
angeht wir werden als bundestagsfraktion
in der nächsten legislatur dass es auch
eine hauptaufgabe auch dort einen
untersuchungsausschuss fordern wir
wollen wissen was es auch dazu geführt
hat dass dieser schneller abzug wieder
von staaten gegen was die gründe waren
was der einsatz uns insgesamt gekostet
hat und was ist eigentlich gebracht hat
wir wollten demokratie in einem land
bringen was dazu nicht bereit war und
wir haben immer wieder im bundestag
darauf hingewiesen wir haben immer
wieder gesagt unsere soldaten dort raus
dieser einsatz bringt uns außerhalb
tränen der mutter von den soldaten die
gestorben sind und viel geld nicht viel
ein und das hat sich bewahrheitet
und auch da wurden wir von
bundesaußenminister maß belogen genauso
wie von verteidigungsministerin frau
kramp karrenbauer die uns immer für den
wolkigen blumen erzählt hat und wir
haben viele brunnen gebohrt und die
zivilgesellschaft hier aufgebaut wurde
die gesellschaft dort war nicht bereit
unser system zu übernehmen und das hat
sich gezeigt wir können nicht eine
ideologie mit einer anderen ideologie
bekämpfen
sie wollen den asyl und migration auf
nationaler ebene letztendlich regeln
genau wir wollen keine quoten zuteilung
auch von von der eu wir wollen selbst
entscheiden wer zu uns kommt wer wen wir
brauchen und das ist denke ich die ihr
haupt prämisse wir haben erlebt die
letzten jahre dass die ungezügelte
migration 4 grad in die sozialsysteme
uns eher soziale probleme gebracht hat
innere sicherheit hat stark gelitten
viele menschen haben angst nachts auf
die straßen zu gehen gerade in
großstädten das können wir ja nicht
einfach so als gegeben hinnehmen und
darauf müssen wir natürlich auch
antworten geben und das wollen wir auch
nicht erweitern und noch mehr dazu
beitragen dass es noch schlimmer wird
das heißt sie würden also suchende auch
an der grenze auch abweisen und auch
familiennachzug ist für sie kein thema
wir wollen das asylsystem in der
dahingehend ändern dass man den
asylantrag grundsätzlich erstmal im
ausland stellen hat und nicht erst in
deutschland denn was haben wir erlebt
aktuell dass gesetze in der form auch
nicht eingehalten werden unser
asylgesetz wird ja nicht eingehalten wer
einmal hier ist bleibt hier das ist
aktuell die gesetzgebung in deutschland
wir haben über 300.000 menschen die
keinen asylgrund in deutschland haben
die auch nachweislich hier nicht bleiben
dürfen aber sie werden nicht abgeschoben
sie bleiben also doch hier es kostet
milliarden euro an sozialleistungen die
der deutsche steuerzahler bringen muss
das muss man den menschen ja erklären
wäre das eigentlich bezahlen soll und
wenn wir nicht konsequent handeln ja
dann bleiben wir weiterhin zufluchtsort
weil natürlich jeder sich sagt ein gutes
leben in deutschland ist möglich ich
muss noch hierher kommen egal wie das
grundrecht sollte man das aus der
verfassung streichen
das asyl grundrecht sollte man nicht aus
der verfassung streichen weil natürlich
politisch verfolgte durchaus ein recht
auf asyl haben aber hier muss man ihm
kein asyl und migration muss man ihm
trennen und es wird in deutschland nicht
getrennt hier wird alles in einen topf
geschmissen und das kritisieren mehr
wenn sie das auf nationaler ebene regeln
wollen
ist schenken denn damit letztendlich tot
nein das hat mit schengen nichts zu tun
das ist schenken kann man mit auf
europäischer ebene ganz anders regeln
wir haben nichts gegen fachkräfte
einwanderung aus bulgarien aus polen aus
ungarn aus italien und portugal
überhaupt nicht das findet aber trotzdem
in die frage sie wollen laut ihrem
wahlprogramm den eu austritt
deutschlands erreichen warum das das ist
in der tat eine maximalforderung weil
wir natürlich sehen was die eu die
letzten jahre und jahrzehnte eigentlich
ja er falsch gemacht hat und wo auch vor
allem nach dem austritt großbritanniens
in der eu kein reformwille entstanden
ist und das erstaunt uns immer mehr dass
auch keine bereitschaft da ist dass wir
weiterhin der größte nettozahler sind
was die kosten angeht und das ist auch
im punkt wo wir natürlich immer wieder
staunen wir haften für die risiken
anderer länder wie portugal spanien
griechenland zahlen immer mehr ein und
das muss auch
ja das ist immer das ist immer das
argument was ich aber widerlegen wenn
ich als als handwerksmeister der selber
ein betrieb hat frage was wo profitiere
ich dann wenn ich als unternehmer 100
euro und wo einzahler und ich bekomme 30
euro wieder dann profitiere ich nicht
dann ist es wirklich eine
milchmädchenrechnung und es stimmt auch
nicht wir zahlen mehr beiträge durch den
austritt großbritanniens allein dieses
jahr 20 jahren zusätzlich die billionen
euro an haftungen kosten die
mittlerweile ins astronomische steigen
die niemand mehr greifen kann oder
versteht wie die auch niemand mehr
verstanden verständnis hat dafür wird
weiterhin in deutschland natürlich als
kostentreiber da sein und deswegen sagen
wir ein totes pferd kann man nicht ewig
reiten man muss auch immer von einem
toten fällt runter steigen deswegen
diese maximalforderung noch dazu ist in
der eu von uns und noch dazu vor ursula
von der leyen kein reformwille erkennbar
die haben eben schon über corona
gesprochen krone hat riesige löcher in
die in dem finanzhaushalt letztendlich
gerissen aber gleichzeitig braucht man
natürlich auch viel geld für die
zukunftsinvestitionen die anstehen hier
unterscheiden sich die ansätze der
parteien
ziemlich was ist denn ihr ansatz wo soll
das geld herkommen diese löcher zu
stopfen ja das ist immer der punkt wo
man natürlich immer auf der
einnahmenseite schaut und die
einnahmenseite ist ja immer die haupt
der hauptpunkt wo steuern erhöht werden
abgaben erhöht werden wir sagen ganz
ganz klar wir müssen uns auch mal die
ausgabenseite ankommen konnte und auch
wirklich ehrlich machen als deutscher
staat und deswegen muss es hier auch mal
ein kassensturz gehen wir müssen sehen
welche einnahmen hat deutschland welche
ausgaben vereinigen können wir endlich
mal bei ausgabenkürzungen mann bringen
weil die steuer lassen abgabenlast ist
in deutschland die höchste mittlerweile
europaweit teilweise weltweit also eine
einnahmenseite kann man nicht weiter
schrauben
abschaffen die grunderwerbssteuer die
erbschafts und schenkungssteuer
kaffeesteuer das glaube ich auch nach
der persönlichen soli ganz abschaffen
die kleinen substanz steuern wie auch
nicht große einfluss auf die steuer
steuereinkommen haben ja haben sie das
mal genau durchgerechnet wenn man
einerseits so ein loch in den kassen hat
dann diese steuern überall abschaffen
will und gleichzeitig die löcher stopfen
muss und eben zukunftsaufgaben männer
und eine frau an geben das habe ich
gerade gesagt und mich wir wollen vor
allem das haben sie vergessen die co2
steuer abschaffen und das ist eine
wichtige steuer die vor allem die vor
allem die vor allem familien belastet
unternehmer handwerker das ist eine
steuer die wirklich an modernen
ablasshandel erinnert und deswegen
ausgabenkontrolle kosten bei der
migration reduzieren eu kosten da haben
wir milliarden beträge wo wir
einsparungen bringen also ich denke eine
refinanzierung ist da durchaus möglich
und es auch durch gebracht oder zum
beispiel die unwahrscheinlich hohen über
550 millionen euro zahlung an eu kinder
ins ausland kindergeldzahlung also dass
wir haben auf der kaufda ausgabenseite
so viele positionen wo wir einsparungen
vornehmen kann die in die hunderte
milliarden gehen und damit habe ich die
gegenfinanzierung gebracht und habe
dabei die eigene bevölkerung die
familien dem mittelstand entlastet
gleichzeitig wollen sie ja auch um die
rente zu sichern
die rente mit einem höheren
steuerzuschuss
ausgleichen das ist auch noch mal noch
wenn man selbst die ausgabenseite dann
reduziert wie sie es gesagt haben kommt
man dann wirklich dahin dass man dann
noch geld hat um zukunftsaufgaben in
angriff zu nehmen die rente immer die
deutschen steuerfinanziert zum teil von
daher wird der wird dieser anteil
steigen das ist richtig das ist
demografisch begründet ja das ist ganz
klar wir wollen aber auch dass mehr zum
beispiel in das rentensystem einzahlen
um damit auch die einnahmenseite zu
erhöhen das ist wichtig zum beispiel
auch politiker wie ich es kann nicht
sein dass wir politiker als ein beispiel
im bundestag genau über diese wichtigen
zukunftsfragen wie sie richtig sagen
sprechen aber selbst eigentlich nicht in
das rentensystem einzahlen das halte ich
ein stück weit auch für doppelmoral und
für ein bisschen unehrlich sie wollen
wenn wir jetzt dann beim klima auch noch
mal sind sie haben mir schon gesagt co2
steuer wollen sie auf jeden fall
abschaffen die landing kohleausstieg ab
sie lehnen eigentlich auch ab den
atomausstieg
das ist in der programmatik her von der
programmatik her wenn man sich
wissenschaftliche expertisen anguckt
schwierig würden sie sagen dass ein sehr
verantwortungsvoller politiker ja da
muss man ein bisschen differenzieren wir
erleben nicht den kohleausstieg papier
steht wir lehnen den vorzeitigen kohle
ausstieg ab das ist richtig weil der
natürlich auch einhergehend mit kosten
hat was die bevölkerung angeht was
stromkosten angeht vor allem ist nicht
geklärt was sind die grund wie wie die
grundlast erhalten werden kann wenn man
diesen vorzeitigen kohleausstieg
bestreitet mit nur mit erneuerbarer
energien wird dieser ausstieg nicht
möglich sein und wenn man sich ehrlich
macht ein industrieland wie deutschland
steigt aus kohle verstromung und
kernkraft verstromung gleichzeitig aus
das wird nicht funktionieren und nur auf
erneuerbare energien geht weil natürlich
die grund das wie gesagt nicht gesichert
ist und weil auch die speicherkapazität
nicht da ist also wenn man von co2
ersparnis wenn man auf diese auf diese
auf diese position 1 geht dann muss man
davon sprechen dass man wieder in die
kernkraft investieren und dass man dort
in forschung und entwicklung investiert
deutschland braucht den energiemix für
alle bereiche für kohle für gas für
strom für kohle vergaß aber auch
natürlich für erneuerbare energien und
das muss ideologiefrei sein und darf
nicht besonders gefördert werden wir mal
richtung verkehrspolitik gucken dann
sagen sie dass das bild die beliebteste
möglichkeit der fortbewegung nämlich die
motorisierte der motorisierte
individualverkehr
dass sie den stärken wollen aber nicht
alles was beliebt ist ist ja unbedingt
zukunftsfähig kann man mit einem solchen
ansatz tatsächlich zukunftspolitik
machen werden muss man die frage stellen
wer bestimmt was zukunftsfähig ist
machen dass politiker oder machen dass
die bürger selbst was sie wollen und was
sie können dann frage ich sie was sollen
im ländlichen raum zukunftsfähig sein
wenn es wenn er wenn die regionalbahn
nicht fährt oder wenn der/die wenn die
infrastruktur gar nicht da ist zum
beispiel um die bürger auf die bahn oder
auf den bus zu bringen also in grad im
ländlichen raum und das ist natürlich
für deutschland wichtig weil der
vernachlässigt wurde die jahre brauchen
mehr weiterhin auch das auto und auch
hier wie gesagt in aixtron setzten den
vielen parteien sehen sie aber hier
brauchen wir doch brauchen wir aber auch
keine vorschriften
das ist ein elektroauto sein muss oder
das ist ein verbrenner auch öl sein muss
auch hier kann man mit alternativen
kraftstoffen mit synthetischen
kraftstoffen hier müssen wir forschung
und entwicklung weiter vorantreiben und
das muss man ein stück weit auch der
wirtschaft selbst überlassen wettbewerb
entsteht durch diese selbst überlassen
sich durch vorschriften des
individualverkehrs
natürlich wollen wir auch die führen wir
auch die förderung grad der
infrastruktur
im ländlichen raum was bus und bahn
angeht ganz klar aber das wurde ja die
letzten jahre alles versäumt ja und das
muss aber erst geschehen bevor man
überhaupt über eine verkehrs veränderung
redet ja und denke das ist das sind
wichtige maßnahmen die wir ergreifen
wollen aber es muss immer im verhältnis
auch sein der verträglichkeit und auch
der kosten für die bürger die müssen im
prinzip auch mitentscheiden dürfen und
müssen auch sagen was sie wollen und die
vertrete ich dann bleibt aus diesem
gespräch die unverrückbare aussage die
ard will raus aus der eu und den d mark
wieder einführen
das sind maximal forderung wenn keine
wie gesagt wenn keine reformierung in
diesen bereichen nötig sind muss sich
deutschland das recht vorbehalten wir
sind der größte nettozahler und auch was
die währung angeht wir waren auch
exportweltmeister vor der eu auch
exportweltmeister mit der d-mark ich
bedanke mich sehr herzlich für das
gespräch und ich bedanke mich bei ihnen
fürs zuschauen was sagen sie unter den
linden spezial mit timo grub am montag
sehen sie zu dieser zeit meine kollegin
eva lindenau mit katrin göring eckardt
die fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
abend phoenix
[Musik]